hello everyone and welcome to another
title tuesday
i do love a good title tuesday who
doesn't
and um we're going to be watching the
creme
de la creme fight it out in
this fantastic online competition
the best i reckon online competition
that is held on a regular basis i mean
you sometimes get 900 titled players
playing and this week well
let's go and have a look shall we who's
going to be playing in a
quick second the game did you start in
under two minutes now
so looking at the list have a look at
some of those
names leading the charge at the top
is hikaru who's that guy anyone anyone
know who he is
what's what's he good yeah yeah he's
pretty handy isn't he
very very strong and he's won this
competition more
than anyone else but he didn't do so
well
last week he lost a couple of games and
he withdrew early
and we can go down the list very briefly
we have the big fish now the big fish is
this incredibly strong player from
russia who knocked out
the well who's been a player who's been
said
tipped to be one of the next world
champion and that is ali raza
and that was a brilliant result by
federsev
and then we have mvl who's leading the
candidates along with
nepo possibly could be playing magnus
carlsen for the world championship match
in niche geary we'll we all love a bit
of a niche gear
don't we uh very funny chap and
the list goes on let's just see well one
player that springs to my eyes here
is daniel naradicki now daniel
is someone i've commentated with before
and he seems like a really
nice guy and i'm really looking forward
to seeing him play uh
so i want to actually have a look at
some of his games today
um i'll be keeping an eye on the
twitch.tv chat so hello to everyone in
the twitch.tv chat how you all doing
hello hello chess pastor uk
hello to mineir hello to
uh everyone else you know who you are
you're all in there
so good to see you there um and it's
gonna be a fun couple of hours so
it is basically um
11 rounds of three minute chests plus
two seconds of move and they are off
well let's start with hikaru
and hikaru with the black pieces here
playing against a russian
feed a master and he's playing the
king's indian defense
now just to just to give you a tip where
my head moves if it goes that way
twitch chat if it goes that way i'm in
trouble because that's where i'm looking
for my commands from chess.com
if it goes this way i'm actually looking
at the chess
i don't know if you wanted to know that
or not but you do now anyway
so um right so hikaru is playing
a favorite kind of setup of bobby
fischer's actually here
bobby fisher in one of his well his most
famous book
my 60 memorable games played
this setup that hikaru is playing but
with the white pieces
and he's turned it around reversed it
and i really like black setup in these
positions because the thing is black is
attacking
white's king and white is attacking on
the queen side
now what's more important the king or
a little pawn over the queen side like
if white breaks through he might win
that pawn there
oh brilliant fantastic if black breaks
through
he's gonna win the king there and he
might even be ready
to sacrifice on h3
as we speak but first of all he's
holding off white's counterplay so
this again if you want to learn this
opening have a look at some of bobby
fisher's games he
played this incredibly well you have
ideas again you've always got to watch
out for the sacrifice this is something
that is is a little bit worrying for
white you know you take here
you bring the bishop down the king is
not very well defended
black can also try to bring his bishop
to some more active square
i suppose if white doesn't get
checkmated
white is doing okay but he's got to
avoid getting checkmated
and hikaru is quite good at check mating
he's only spent
12 seconds getting to
this position um
so well yeah i mean again hello to chess
vibes i hope that's peter good uh good
to see you in in the chat peter
and um i mean bobby
loved the king's indian defense um the
opening that he car
is playing i'm really happy to see top
players playing the kings in defense
because it's an opening i love a lot as
well it's so exciting
uh but what's happening here well can
hikaru go knight takes e3
i think that was quite a basic tactic
that
white just fell into there let's just
have a look at that again um
we had this normal position where white
is absolutely fine if i was white here
i'd probably try to go knight b3 i want
to get the queens off the board because
when your king is under danger
get the queens off but he played knight
d5
which is quite poor calculation and
after knight takes knight
the bishop has to be exchanged but then
hikaru has this move which is called an
intermezzo
rather than taking that back which might
also be okay
he can go knight takes e3 threatening
the queen
and after some more moves we get to the
current position
but hikaru is simply a pawn up and look
at this
really weak pawn there on e3 this is
already losing for white
i find this um quite
quite weird it's quite psychological
people don't really talk about
the psychological side of chess enough
but when you're playing a legend
like hikaru you kind of overthink things
you should play more naturally
and here i think white just thought oh
i'm playing hikaru
and he probably didn't play as well as
he normally would and
rook d1 now played what's the the
bar here the evaluation bar has gone
a little bit crazy well totally crazy
why is it he's got look at that plus
seven so i wonder what the win was there
was there a forced win bishop takes h3
why didn't hikaru play bishop takes h3
oh look at that just call me the new
hikaru who needs hikari when you've got
the ginger beard
why didn't hikaru play that the simple
point being if you take the bishop back
check and that's what i call a juicy
check so that's that's a little bit
strange from hikaru maybe not a good
sign
of course he's still doing very well
here in the position
he's a pawn up but he could have come he
could have won another pawn
very easily there so that's
a little bit a little bit peculiar but i
think we're going to move on i think
it's pretty clear that hikaru will win
this game now i did mention daniel
naradicki and well let's go over to his
game he's actually playing
another grand master from india
and i'm not going to click on the name
but you guys if you want to check
who their real handle is do log in to
chess.com well there you go ah i just
saw a very cute picture of daniel
ah it's a picture of him when he's about
three years old holding a chess trophy
obviously an early starter and here
white resigned
because black is crashing through on
f2 queen takes f2 is coming and
well it's pretty hard to stop that one
um
right so we will now go and jump into
another game
and we're gonna have a look at mvl and
this position
looks much more even nvl
playing m is that is that from
egypt so there's not many egyptian chess
players
and in this position well you would say
that black is better because black has
this very
active bishop and good rook when you're
trying to assess the position you should
look at
two things the pawn structure and the
pieces
and you know even if it takes you a lot
of time it's a great way to improve
look at who's got the better pawn
structure here
white might have the better pawn
structure because this pawn
on d6 is very weak if you've got a bad
pawn structure
you better make sure that your pieces
are very active
to compensate for that and in actual
fact having peace activity and better
pieces
is often more important than having a
good pawn structure because
good pieces mean good tactics and
tactics
win the game and in this position well
all the black's pieces to me look very
scary maybe the knight will now come to
d4
this is the kind of thing that's
possible put the knight on this square
here
okay mvl is coming in with the idea of
checking
and winning the bishop and obviously
time
is a very big consideration here
so the white king trying to run away
but now the knight does come in and this
should now
surely be all over with black
winning a piece um g5 here very sensible
move
black is a piece up and this is going to
be the end of the game the black king
can march in as well but mvl
has other ways of doing it very nice
tactic night e3 is coming
these these top players they see tactics
immediately
immediately um hello
codders hope you're doing all right
you're going to make a book on this
title tuesday i'm very interested to
know who you think's going to win it
obviously if we're talking about who is
favorite and you can keep
an eye on the live scores below i'm only
going to be looking at the top 10
boards um you can go again into the
chess.com playing arena to look at more
boards
but if you have a look at the top 10
players i mean
hikaru is always favorite because he's
won it more than anyone
um now who else do i think some of the
young
indian players have done incredibly well
in this tournament
so arjun could be a dangerous bet but
he's never won it
so let's move down and we will go
a little bit more now drop stone who
is a young russian player and help me
out with his name there in the chat i'm
sure some of you watched my show last
week
um is he he came
first equal i think last week is that
right so he's he's
he's going to be one to look out for
eric hanson
we all love eric hansen because he was
brilliant he was one of the original
twitch streamers so we got a lot to
thank for the chess bras and
the energy that he brought to streaming
and uh yeah that's right so um
just to remind you who dropstone is it's
david
paravan who i can never pronounce as the
end of his name correctly
but david paravan and someone needs to
say it to me so i can say it properly
being dyslexic but you get the idea
david paravan
won its last week so dropstone did win
it last week
um and if we have a look at some other
players well this is mama jaroff
who had a very bad loss in the last
round last week but
good player we all know who anish is i
love to see
niche do well he's never won it in niche
unless i'm wrong so maybe it's his time
you got champ here champ 2005
another young indian dangerous
and strong player i don't know who's
going to win it
who is going to win it who's going to
win it okay come on guys i want to hear
your suggestions
while okay we're just uh we'll see that
there's oh look at that checkmate
can we just have a look at this
checkmate okay so hang on a minute look
at this position here
this position okay this is a very
exciting
end to the game so white is coming down
the board this way and black
oh hang on let me get this right no
black
is coming this way and white is coming
this way they both
queen at the same time
so you would have thought draw right
it's a draw because they both got queens
on the board
the time limit is three minutes oh let
me get this right it is
plus two seconds no one second to move i
always get that wrong
so you shouldn't get flagged because you
get a little bit of increment and now
black plays a
lovely little finish can you guys see
the finish
can you guys see the finish here
can you work it out black to play and
checkmate that'll give me a chance to
have a little swig of my tea
even money on hikaru hikaru really
you're going to go even money on hikaru
i i would actually have a little a
little
i no offense to hikar maybe that's a you
you are the odd maker
uh and when we're talking about we're
just talking about in friendly ways
how we think people would do well uh
giri or dania i would go
on dania i would go on daniel
um okay so the finish is
queen to e7 check and of course there's
no
point to only seeing the first move and
this is really nice this is actually
like a textbook finish where does the
king go now if the king goes to this
square
what is the winning move here what is
the winning move let's oh round two
starting
the winning move is this subtle little
move with checkmate coming in
and after the king comes here check and
mate okay we better get on to round two
though let's go round two caught there
quick here today
right now i'm going to go with daniel
naray dixie because
let's go pick up from the first moves
and he's playing farhad
rahman of bangladesh an international
master who has a decent rating so
daniel starts with e4 the rule lopez or
spanish
if you can't pronounce the rule lopez
maybe i should just call it the spanish
main line bishop e7 and now
well this is um one of the least sharp
lines this is a safer line
um the main line is where white
basically plays
rookie one and tries to avoid moving
with d3 the reason that white doesn't
play d3
is because white wants to play d4 so the
main line is something like rookie one
castles and now c3 because if white can
go
d4 and get another pawn to d4 that's
really handy two pawns in the center but
then black has some martial moves
and it gets very complex so the way
that daniel played this he's playing it
a bit more slower and he's stopping the
dangerous
gambit lines and he plays here a3
very important when you're playing this
opening to keep
hold of your light square bishop and the
rule is as soon as black plays d6
he guards this pawn so black has a
positional
fret and the positional threat is knight
a5
winning that bishop or not winning but
getting rid of it and you don't want to
lose this bishop as white
because it's a really good attacker
that's why you play a3 because now
if the bishop is attacked it has a
little home to go to
um of course you're getting a master
class on the opening here i bet you
didn't want that but you're getting one
anyway
tough luck at castles knight bd2
simple stuff h3 and now
rook e1 this knight is getting ready to
travel to g3
d4 bishop g5 and now we have this
as the current position
uh this is the current position um
as we are and of course someone brings
me on the phone
typical uh luckily i turned off the
noise so if you hear a vibrating noise
it is just my phone so in
this position uh here well
this is a standard idea dating back
oh actually maybe maybe okay no i was
just checking
it it wasn't gary kasparov for someone
in this position this is a standard idea
where the knight well it dominates this
bishop and the threat was to win that
bishop when you can see the power
of the bishop on b3 and this is another
normal idea you could take with the e
pawn or with the g pawn if you take the
g
pawn you aim to check mate on g7 if you
take with the e pawn you're playing much
more positional
where white now has this lovely square
for the knight
look at that square and you can just see
how powerful this bishop is that's why
you want to keep
that bishop this is really a masterclass
in how to play
the rule lopez from daniel i mean look
at that i
love i love that bishop so strong and i
think daniel has a couple of ways
now to go he can go h4 and g5
h4 and g5 is a is one
way hence why black has aimed to try and
stop that idea
and now maybe just bishop a2 okay daniel
has swapped that one off
he goes rookie four and i'm sure he's
gonna get ready to play g5 at some
moment
because the point is if he can open up
the h file
all he needs to do is get a heavy piece
a rook
or a queen on the h file and it's
checkmate so
here we come real textbook stuff real
real so i i am in love chess patsy yuko
i'm in love
i'm in love with daniel's play in this
opening whoa
it's good stuff right now i am hearing
that
um levy is is winning against anish
geary i don't know if that's true
um let's just see if that's going on are
they i don't know if they
are they playing is this levy no that is
that is a lie okay thank you for making
me go oh no it's true it is going on
okay let's have a look at that because i
know a lot of you are big fans
of both of these players uh it looks
like daniel narutsky was winning
so we just have a look at this game two
of the most popular
youtubers and um well
streamers around who've done great
things for chess
gotham chess and anish and i have to say
looking at this position it looks pretty
terrible for uh for black this looks not
just pretty terrible it looks horrible
um it's for white i got i got it mixed
up there for white
black has two bishops for the rook
which is which is pretty strong and
black has
these pawns in the center of the board
just about to
come on down the you know this is
completely crushing
knight here threatening the rook maybe
this bishop can come round to c5
another thing you should look for when
you're playing you've got to look for
you've got to look
for maybe this one is good you've got to
look for
targets in your opponent position there
was an old book on attacking chess which
called these
targets focal points
you can call them whatever you want they
don't need to have a pacific name
but the point is you've got to find a
square in your opponent's position
like f2 which you think okay that's a
target
and then you just got to bring your
pieces in
to target that square as the bishop
comes in here
i won't swap around games in the future
i don't like jumping games
uh generally so i am a bit sorry for
going from daniel narrow dixie's game
but this is obviously a big
big game and now the two bishops are
dominating
there's no threat on the seventh rank
because the bishop on f6
is so strong and we're just gonna see oh
oh
oh oh oh what happened
he just blundered a whole piece a niche
went mental
he blundered a whole piece i mean well
not a niche yeah niche black
what happened he wanted a little
that was that that went what happened
there
um well i mean let's just have a look at
that he won
on time oh there
i was i mean this position easily
winning
easily winning for a niche all he needs
to do is not
blunder any pieces can we call him
blunder a niche from now on
and he just has to go d3 d2
d1 queen thank you very much it's not
that hard push the pawn
go here i mean you can just support it
with your bishops but instead
he played this howler this
howler bishop c2
ah i think everyone should go into his
stream now
and tight bishop c2 bishop c2 bishop c2
a niche weak bishop c2 go on go and do
it
i'll have a little drink while you go do
that that's all you need to do is go
over there right
weak bishop c2 don't actually do that it
might game of trouble we'll do if you
want to do if you want to be would be
quite funny
i mean bishop c2 and now rook takes c2
and all of a sudden here after this rook
a2 i'm not sure i like that one if i was
white i would have gone
rook c7 because the point is
if a5 we can win another piece and you
never know the way anish was dropping
them he might drop another one
um but in the end it was decided on the
clock
with a niche playing very quickly levy
did
have one second increment per move but
the final position to be fair
is not so clear i think a niche is
absolutely fine because he's secured
both his pawns
and this pawn could become really
dangerous and niche is certainly
not worse in this position
certainly not worse
i'm having a look at the chat okay
remember if i look left i'm in trouble
yeah if i look left that's where i'm in
trouble don't make
don't make everyone leave the stream to
go to anisha's
no they wouldn't say that nothing
nothing bad going on
um okay any more games let's have a look
do keep an eye on the scores
now another player a couple of players
who
are um maybe not so well known but
always do well in this event
is jos pem who is an incredibly
talented player from peru um he
obviously doesn't get the chances that a
lot of european
players play he doesn't play many
competitions but he always does well in
this chopper
chopper mate choppa i remember it as an
australian guy called chopper i watched
the film
about some crazy australian lunatic
anyone watch that one choppa
choppa that's my australian accent
pretty pretty
shambolic right i don't hate any
kangaroos around
give us a foster's um yeah i'll probably
get kicked out of australia for talking
like that
um oh and we got the big p daddy
the big p daddy isn't number two peter
svidler
and does he need an introduction there's
some people who just don't need an
introduction
he's one of them i'll give him one
anyway now is he
how many times has peter svidler won the
russian championships
come on without googling no googling
don't google
how many times has he won the russian
championships come on guys
tell me who's gonna how i mean anyone
who's won
the russian championships as many times
as peter swidder
is a legend the russian championships
the hardest
championships to win probably because
they're russian
um i think it's eight times
i think it's eight times uh a hundred
maybe a little bit optimistic he's gotta
live to a very nice age to get that one
but he's won it so many times he's a
fantastic player round three
cool you don't get much of a break do ya
okay now
let's go to he car
shall we let's go to hikaru now
um hikaru let's go for the opening moves
has played
g6 okay so the modern opening now hikaru
does
play quite risky openings
and the perk is a risky opening this is
a
i'd say not his first challenge but a
grand master 2700 they're pretty handy
i'm i'm one of them
on chess.com but i'm actually a bit
lower than that
and now i always think f4 is the best
move here just in case you're wondering
about it this is the most testing get
free pawns coming at you
bishop e3 is actually called the 180
attack and the reason for that is on the
english chess circuit this is what i
heard
is that many english players just went
queen d2
and when black castle kingside bishop h6
h4 h5 took on g6 swapped the bishops off
brought the queen to h6
and chet mated on h7 and they were all
graded about 180 or was it 160 attack i
don't know one of those two
um okay so let's go on and we
now have a more positional approach and
i think this is the wrong way to play
you know you're playing hikaru who's a
great player
take him on take him on start throwing
your h pawn up him start throwing your f
pawn at him
don't mess around with positional ideas
because
the longer the game goes on um i would
say
the better that hikaru chances are and
now he plays this very interesting move
b5
this shows his tactical vision he's
trying to take the knight away from
c3 okay someone's now telling me it's
the 150 attack
so i said the 180 then i went to 160
and now i've got to go 150 okay
um there we go and now g5 again i don't
like this move either i mean the idea of
this
is to win a pawn but is it overextending
let's have a look so now white gets very
greedy
and white has won that pawn
okay well you know he at least white is
taking the game to hikaru so let's give
i will give him some credit and
this position whites are pawn up
but there's something about black
white's position over on the king's side
which i don't like too much
there seems to be a lot of holes over
here and
you know a bit of pressure in the center
i mean i guess white's doing well
but this is interesting so okay we'll
keep an eye on it we keep
an eye on this one i'm heard i'm hearing
that anish
is not streaming is that the case he's
not streaming he's trying to win it
okay well anish's odds have dropped then
if he's not streaming
or improved i think is what i meant to
say
uh now it's two pawns up so why
is white winning i mean if white doesn't
do something really stupid white's doing
well because what how did he win another
pawn
okay now let's have a look look okay
this looks really bad for
for black because where's black's
counter play so white has defended this
well he's defending that one
he's stopping the knight coming in here
by defending that and he's now playing a
very sensible move
get the queens off the board if you swap
the queens
off the board you take out a lot of
tactical chances and he's got this big
pawn
push push it baby um h4 was that really
necessary he could have gone before and
got his rook behind the pawn let's just
have a look at that
i mean one thing you get when you know
you've got a winning position you get
scared just throw the pawn up the board
if you have a past pawn there's no point
just hello mate
that you've got you've got to lob it
you've got to throw it and this would
have been much better because a rook
behind the past pawn is very strong
because it supports the pawn
coming up the board but if we go back to
the game he's allowed
hikaru to get a hold on that pawn and
he's still trying to swap off maybe this
is a bit too much swapping
but he's gone bishop g4 and okay it's
still good for white
but i would have preferred for white to
get that pawn
motoring up now who what do we reckon
is is hikaru still going to win this one
i mean it's possible
it's very possible but white is playing
very well still
this knight has potential to come in and
the black king
is now the new target so white
can he bring he can go here and come
into f6 but he's trying to swap off more
pieces
i kind of like the way white's doing
this i wouldn't play like this because i
think white's saying okay look
um i oh it's mate it's mate
it's mate surely no knight f5 knight f5
is mate
and now this checkmate boom
and quickly oh i don't i don't really
want to watch shikara's face now
but that was a real result for emperor
a real upset there congratulations
it's not easy beating hikaru so
well done to emperor 87 and the books
are going crazy
the books are going crazy hikaru has
lost the game
he's not the favorite any more
i mean he's got to win all of the
remaining games i'd imagine there's 11
rounds
there's no um like knockout at the end
it's just called a swiss system whoever
has the best score
after 11 rounds and if there's two
people on the same score they do it on
tie break which is this number
next to the score and the higher your
tie break
uh the more chance you have which i very
nicely cut off there so i might i might
just
try to readjust that in a second um
twelve to one now hikaru okay well let's
let's have a look any other games going
on let me just uh bring them up
12 to one i'd probably have a little i'd
probably have a little bet on 12 to one
but
it does depend it does depend if um
hikaru you know uh goes on tilt
hikaru seems to be uh quite an emotional
player
and he's a really good player he's the
best blitz player in the field
but when he's rolling he can just roll
over the whole field
but sometimes when he you know loses a
game
he goes a little bit on tilt so you know
he can upset him a lot and
i'm very similar to that myself meaning
that you know i i often like you know i
i've lost that game i get really annoyed
with myself uh really annoyed
unfortunately codders i i don't
i don't have a chance to really whatsapp
while i'm doing this there's too many
things going on
maybe another day when they got another
commentator i'll get involved but
not this time so anyway back to this
game and this is the second seed
big fish oh it's great to see shiroff in
second place
as i've mentioned in previous weeks
shiroff
is one of my favorite players and okay
uh
russian technique there and you can see
that black's king is getting forced all
the way back
uh shear off one of my favorite players
he's been a legend of mine for a long
time
and as in you know he's uh
he he's he's he's just been up there
fighting in a really
tactical manner he is mr fire on the
board
uh so um yeah it's great
it's great um okay so a lot of names i
don't recognize here i'm just gonna see
if there's any more games going on
they're probably all finishing now and
let's just see if we can
quickly update this so we can see oh a
niche is at the top
okay i feel like it might be a niche's
time
to to to do something in this event mvl
lost we're being told as well
to an fm well you know fm's can be
incredibly good at blitz
it's it's is possible um who else don't
i really know
now i'm just i'm going through these
names there's a lot of players
um so a lot of upsets there's a lot of
upsets and let's say shear off i
love to see alexei with it he'd be my i
like to see him win it more than anyone
else
an old legend um
alexander fear is a very aggressive and
entertaining player um
and we're hearing rumors i don't know if
there's just rumors in the chat
someone's saying hikaru working on a ban
uh for for the guy really uh
i don't know i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
speculate too much
but um i always love it when you know uh
someone loses and they're like
oh ban him he must be cheating um
renuk how is i don't know
is it roonac roonak i'm gonna say is is
playing this time
is he playing let's have a look i don't
know i'm going to see
he's a young player from india who does
excel
in this tournament a really good blitz
player eric hanson on three out of three
as well um and i'm just going to keep
going down
daniel naradicki on three out of three
good stuff we have a
look at his game jabarva we haven't
mentioned
the ever interesting and dynamic
jabarva so that's also good
uh he's up there with three out of three
who's this guy vidit anyone know who he
is
vivit of course a legendary legendary
player i'd love to see him play gyri
they often stream together
um and let's keep going down creek
is one of the may the main streamer for
brazil
um really nice guy chilled out chilled
out giza
and we keep going down lawrence trent
whoa okay i'm gonna have to look at
lawrence trent's game i'm gonna have to
i'm sorry i know you might be saying not
trent
not that trendy we're gonna have to look
if i can find his name
laurence is a good mate of mine and
um okay while i try to find his game
i'll put you on this one
anisha's game and the niche is playing
black against branded
jacobson uh where is where is uh
maybe now lawrence has pulled out the
tournament because he knows
he's pushed you know he's going to pull
out the tournament say well i was
winning it i was winning the tournament
my internet went down i was leading what
odds are we getting on lawrence trent
what odds are we getting on lawrence
trent that's that's what i want to know
he's so far down the list oh he's
playing sheer off
ah we've got to look at this ah okay
sorry i'm getting excited
so this is laurence trent who you must
have heard of
and he's playing the legendary shear off
and it goes with d4
and laurence trent has got his perfect
opening in
can he take down shear off c5
now c5 in my opinion is not
a particularly brilliant move because of
lawrence's next move
e4 and the point of this move e4
is that after black takes you go d5 and
this is where pattern
recognition is very important i'm going
to twist the boards
for one second to show you what my point
is my point is
lawrence trent is especially a
speciality
player in what we call the albion
counter gambit
which is this move here with e5 and
after taking lawrence plays d4
now the way he's got this with white
he's got an extra
tempo in the position so if we switch
the board back and i've probably messed
up everything now i'm very good at that
and we just reload the point now
lawrence has got his dream position
but he's got an extra developed piece so
let's keep going
he now develops very normally queen e2
now i did analyze this line quite a lot
and it's very dangerous for black
because this pawn is a real thorn
but after knight takes e5 i think i came
to the conclusion that black
should play very calmly and just take
this one but shear off goes for queen a5
trying to start a counter attack king b1
and now bishop f5 lining up these
bishops so this is
really really interesting stuff
now um this position i mean the albion i
mean
obviously computers don't like pawn
sacrifices they don't pay much attention
to the evaluation bar
but one thing we can say is that this
position is
extremely interesting and shiroff now
lining his queen up now this is
lawrence moving that attacked bishop
back
and there is a threat here of g4
trapping
the bishop on f5 what odds are we going
to get on this game
anyone want to speculate on this game
here what is going to happen on this
game
um i'm going to say this could be an
upset i'm going to go for an alexei
shearer wins
an upset according to lawrence it would
be uh no i don't know i'm gonna go
um i i don't know it's gonna be i i
could see trent winning this one
trent can sometimes do it this is a
crafty move
because it stops this one but now what
lawrence is going to try and do is play
g4
but alexei is bringing more pieces
directly in towards the king so it's a
really exciting position
if alexei can get rid of this knight
then his bishop will be threatening to
take on c3
so this is typical shirov shirov
attacking
with everything okay so now lawrence
changing his mind
probably and he's just trying to swap
off that attacking piece it does seem to
me i have to oh
i don't like that move because of d6 but
then alexa is going to play knight d5
so he's done this one to get a hold on
this square so his knight can come here
but now
what is happening what is happening this
is getting crazy
knight takes d5 knight takes as shiroff
is sacrificing has he got knight to c
free check
has he got this move if pawn takes here
oh okay so let's have a look at that so
my point is if you take the bishop
can alexa play boom and you have to take
this one and then alexa goes this is
why i'm called mr far on the board
checkmate is coming
you're just the trent i'm the sheriff
put that in your pipe and smoke it young
boy
so here lawrence gets rid of that knight
he now takes on f5 and after queen g2
black gets his rook into a very
dangerous position knight f3
and here rook to e8 and i have to say
looking at the position
i think i think we could have an upset
the queen is coming in the bishop is
coming in trent
is on fire lawrence is
on fire is he going to do this queen
takes d5
check look at this attacking position
this must be good
this must be winning for lawrence queen
and knight
are very very good attacking pieces i
knew this would be a good game
these two players very exciting
someone's saying jameson trenty sipping
a glass of wine i expect he's sipping a
bottle of wine
oh come on cheer off
give me that red wine and then he goes
check mate sheer off
here we go thank you for the game i am
the trent
okay so bishop it must be quite
off-putting playing
uh against lawrence because uh um
you know you uh he he's he's very
dangerous and he's very well known but
he hasn't won the position yet
now what he's done is quite a clever
maneuver because i think he wants to
position his bishop here
so if the rook comes down
can he do that well let's have a look
rook here look at the time as well i'm
not going to move pieces on the board
because the situation on the clock will
lawrence
choke this is the question choking means
will he actually win this or will he be
like no
and will he choke will he will he choke
will he throw it away now after queen
takes black's only hope is to go queen
e1
and take on c1 so queenie one
must be played or queen h1 one of these
moves but 16 seconds left
and the problem here oh he's not done it
he's not done it lawrence should be
winning can he hold it together they're
both under 20 seconds
and shear off is former top three in the
world
and he's still a very aggressive player
lawrence is
at the moment completely winning
completely winning he can
check and win this pawn somehow queen e4
queen e4 get the queens off lawrence
queen e4 get those queens off but he's
trying
to come round with some checks so he can
take that pawn very sensible play
um well that's what i thought he was
doing i'm not sure what he's trying to
do now what's he doing
why is he going backwards and forwards
lawrence
go queen b8 take the b pawn come on
laurence just take those pawns
okay he's found the move he's got to win
this one he's he's a hundred million
pawns up
now he's gonna what's he trying to do
now don't get too greedy
okay what's he doing he's gonna be
careful perpetual oh
dear um okay um
so this must be winning but he's making
a pig's ear of it because the problem is
queen e1 was checkmate so he now has
stopped that one so let's just show that
i i didn't actually see that myself so
in this position actually
let's keep with the game sorry i don't
want to move away from the game he's won
he's won well done lawrence
absolutely brilliant and i just want to
show the end of that game
one part this is actually a trick that i
might have fallen in for
um in this position if you ever play
queen take c4
look at that evaluation bar that was
that was a pretty
shocking topple um queenie one checkmate
but lawrence has
won very well done lawrence very well
done
it might have been bad technique but it
got there in the
end now we are going to take
a short break uh i now i believe that
was round four
lawrence on four out of four
congratulations
and i would like to thank a youtube
uh user um as well
and that youtube user is um
is it fabian four seven one
one who gave a little donation so thank
you there
and i'm gonna take a little a little
break well done to lawrence that is uh a
brilliant
victory over one of the best players in
the world and
well actually before i do take a break
it does seem that
anish is still playing okay i say that
and who won and niche
lost a niche lost to
brandon jacobson so niche has lost so
daniel naradicki how is he getting on
daniel
is on maximum as well okay so we'll be
back in no time at all
we're only gonna be back we're only
gonna take a short break
time to restock or restock on your tea
coffee whiskey or wine or whatever you
drink
and uh i'll be back uh yeah with more of
the action remember it's 11 rounds
we've only had four rounds there's a
load to go a load of excitement
can laurence trent pull off can he pull
off
i was going to say so rude there can you
pull off the most
amazing upset victory entitled tuesday
that has ever occurred
in the history of mankind be back soon
[Music]
it's looking really ominous especially
given that he's down on time this is the
magnus carlson squeeze
um wow hicaro's playing in front of
hundreds of people
imagine being in his shoes right now i
mean
up by four games well i can resign yeah
carl knows it it started with 16 players
and uh it all came down to one man
magnus carlson
[Music]
this is a pretty great matchup i know
people love hikaru nakamura
hikaru is the favorite for a reason he's
the beast
an absolute monster it has been hecaro's
speech his championship this 2018 in
kara nakamura the overall one c takes it
home in the species championship
obviously this is a rematch of last
year's scc final what a finish by the
way i mean that's been the story of the
match the kara nakamura has just kind of
out swindled out tricked and out
calculated wesley in the critical moment
dude that's a nice move wesley's shaking
his head
i call her winston he's going to draw
this game i can't believe it which
happened unbelievable okay carlo
nakamura holding that position he had no
business drawing that game
[Music]
okay so it's been a very exciting
uh i feel uh first four rounds i mean
this has been great and
you know it's always nice to see uh a
friend do well
you're gonna be biased aren't you if you
see a good a good mate uh
taking out a big name and the big news
so far
if you've only just joined in joined the
stream why have you done that you're in
trouble
is that lawrence trent took down
alexei shirov which is a fantastic
result for lawrence so well done
now one thing a lot of people joke about
lawrence you know i've seen him on
streams and
they joke about his strength now i do
want to say
he's a really good player he could be a
grand master he's just shown that in
that game he's got a lot of potential
i think the only reason people joke
about him it's normally magnus carlsen
joking about him and magnus carlsen get
away of joking about anyone's strength
because he's different gravy so
well done um and having a look at the
scores
let's have a look at the top and see
what is going on at the top there sorry
i had it on dim screen so you can have a
look
a number of people on four out of
four and we have um
becca 95 now i don't know the real name
of that now you can
go and check out their their actual
handles if you want to go into the
chess.com
live chess and just follow the title
tuesday event
alongside this is anyone watching this
on the tv by the way
i've just worked out how to watch twitch
broadcasting tv
when i can sit back on the sofa you know
and just be like oh yeah it's a bit of
danny wrench
hello danny you know just put my feet up
on the big screen
it's very very relaxing i don't know or
where are you watching i'm kind of
interested
anyway let's go through the list so we
have arjun who
is this amazingly talented uh
player junior from india who's this guy
who's this guy eric hanson oh yes i've
heard of him
from poland don't know this guy so well
um and going down the list we want to
have a look blitz streamers up there
another famous famous streamer
who's on maximum points that's really
good to see and
um there's a lot of people on four so
i'm just going to keep going down
and this is dimitri adriaking i think
lawrence trent as we know again federsev
who's the second seed on maximum as
well um brandon jacobson
who beat geary geary blundering a lot
today
maybe he's drunk no i i don't mean that
of course maybe just having a bad day
daniel naradicki on four points as well
so
there are 26 people still
on maximum points and we're in now
um let me just update the games update
please i might have to do a little
refresh who should we look at who should
we look at
let's do a little refresh and
i'm going to go i mean i'm tempted to go
laurence trent but that might annoy a
lot of you
so we're going to go and have a look at
eric hanson instead let's have a look at
eric
so eric has the white pieces he's on
maximum he's playing
lag manta from russia and it has started
with a caracan and he plays this system
which is quite
popular and now
after this move knight to f6 is now the
trendy
move to play this is like the trendy
variation and now eric plays a really
safe move he plays d3
and he basically says i want to take you
into an ending
this is this is really strange i was
assumed eric was a very aggressive
attacking player but he's allowing the
end game to occur here
so he's now playing a bit like off
anderson or some
in-game legend and it goes on
i might not be looking at this game too
much because it's not the most exciting
but we will get up to date with the
position
and here well i think the strategy has
worked out very well
because there's a big tactical threat or
bishop takes
b7 this idea of putting the bishop on b7
is not a good idea
you need the bishop to defend the knight
there you need the bishop to defend the
knight
and the problem here is what does black
play if black castles
queen side eric wins a pawn if black
plays king e7 which would be natural to
try getting a rook in
you still take the pawn and you're going
to go rook takes d7 next
so instead oh my words oh my
words i thought this was going to be a
long end game grind
instead black found another way now
what's what you want
if you're in life if you have to blunder
either a pawn or a piece
stick with a pawn that's my wise words
of the day
if you've got a choice a pawn or a piece
do the piece
he castles boom and now
rook takes d7 oh dear
right i hear the crowd is going crazy
for a bit of trent
action and is he doing it again he's
doing it again
laurence can we all here at lawrence can
we all hear a trent in the chat
come on i'm gonna do it trinity
come on come on trendy trunty
okay there we go and i think he's got a
good position here again
right i mean he's got two pieces for the
rook
and look at his pieces they're coming in
this must be good for lawrence he's
playing a grand master from russia
a young grandmaster from russia and
hello to um ruland in the chat as well
and now he's just keeping it very simple
now the rule is
really if you have two pieces for the
rook that is a very good thing the two
pieces work much better than one rook on
its own
unless you get really deep into the
ending
if you get into a late ending the rook
comes to life
but there was a big threat of knight
takes there now can he do something with
knight here
this must be good for trent if he just
or maybe knight f4
knight f4 just try and take this one
with knight f4
the knight can come into e2 this is
really good for lawrence
are you gonna get to five out of five
get what's he done why is he so good
what is that oh come on lauren oh i
see i was about to blunder a piece with
this one
when that was the move but here you can
even go king e8 here
because if rook takes here knight e2
check would a one but he's
maybe getting a little bit nervous this
is kind of the move which shows a little
bit of nerves but he's still doing well
he's still doing well the king
goes back here and we have more moves
i'm hoping that it's going to
automatically update
and now more pieces getting swapped off
i don't know
if this is the right strategy from
lawrence i don't think you should be
swapping off pieces
because like i mentioned before
the king and rook are actually very good
in the ending i don't like the way
lawrence is doing this i'm not sure
about this anymore
i know that he's got a big advantage
he's got to get this knight in the game
where is that knight going
is he going to go g5 and bring it here
it's not clear i would yeah this is
better let's try to get
the knight somewhere good but where e5
that's where you want to get the knight
to
so how do you get the knight to e5 maybe
king here and knight d7
this would be a good idea get the knight
to this square so in order to get it
there you need to get it to d7
in order to get it to d7 you need to
move your king out the way
so i like king v8 knight d7 knight e5
he's gone this way where's that knight
going the one thing with knights
you've got to find the best route for
them and if anyone's improving their
position
it's now white white is coming in with
the king
i don't come on laurence you're you're
you're i don't like this
okay now he's trying to trap that rook
he still probably is better
but look what white's doing whites look
at the knight why is he put the knight
there
when you're trying to find root for your
knight make sure you okay you can go
no he's gone back he should have gone to
a8 then b6 and then here and then here
where's that night going i don't think
morris has a clue what he's doing here
lawrence come on man you've gotta you
gotta you've gotta
get get a grip on this um
did it drop a pawn was i dropping a pawn
with king d8 i didn't see that okay
maybe i was i mean
so his new idea is to get the knight to
f6
um but i mean of course
white shouldn't win this one because
white can't do anything hang on a minute
hang on a minute it's nearly checkmate
here
oh okay what was the move there there
was a big swing
he could have played knight takes h5 oh
no
lawrence and this would have gone knight
g3 and if rook takes you go g6 check
so lawrence misses a chance and instead
he goes back to doing some slow
maneuvers
bishop f6 g4 and he's got to find a way
to break through and he's now bringing
the king back
i'm i'm a little bit worried that
lawrence really has no idea what he's
doing
am i allowed to say that lawrence i can
and here
now the king can come back again king f7
and lawrence has got to try and make pro
i don't see how he's making progress
i don't see how he's going to do it the
only thing he could try is get his
knight to this square this is what i've
tried so knight d7 is he going to
finally try this one no
he's coming back he's gaining a little
bit of time on the clock
he's going back again this is going to
be a perpetual this is going to be a
perpetual
and now i just don't see how he's going
to do this he hasn't found the right
plan here
he's going backwards and forward
um knight h7 can you try that one
where's the knight going no he's going
for the draw no
lawrence and maybe white is even going
to try to win
by playing g5 i think lawrence has said
i can't win this
i'm going to take the draw and this must
be a draw knight d7 you've got to play
this move he's played it
good boy good boy because at least now
he can put the knight
on this square and that is some kind of
progress i think because now the rook
is passive and you've got to try now no
don't move the knight away don't move
the night away get your king to g5
i mean it might be a draw it might be a
draw um
the position anyway but i mean in a real
game you'd think
oh rookie six could have been quite
strong there no um there's still a lot
going on this
could still change anyone think he's
going to lose anyone think he's going to
lose anyone i think lauren is going to
lose this he has
actually kind of thrown this away right
uh but now white is looking a bit
dangerous white's getting the rook in
here oh no don't lose this one
don't lose this one lawrence please
don't oh no
he's getting very short of time oh no oh
no
lawrence no lawrence what are you doing
man
what are you doing oh this is painful
come on push the h pawn and pray
push the h pawn and pray why is it
oh i don't know if i can watch much more
of this to be honest
this is getting a little bit too painful
it's like
you know it's like oh dear it's like
watching someone with a terminal disease
in hospital isn't it this it's like you
know
you know you like the guy and it's just
oh no oh no
lawrence oh no what have you done
what have you done man oh no
oh dear this is this is just not good
and the d pawn is now queening and
um oh no i it's a pity laurence is not
streaming this as that would be
very funny but this is this is just
getting more painful
get ready for the funeral get ready for
the funeral it's not going to be
pleasant
and you can see in disgust he's playing
on but
uh i don't know why i'm even looking at
this game it's kind of one of those
morbid things
where you just have to watch it until
the end you know and
oh no oh no that was an absolute
travesty i have to say he played so well
he played so well laurence and he ended
up losing oh laurence oh
lawrence oh laurence that was actually i
think um primo
man defined that well it was just a car
crash
that was a car crash to watch wasn't it
he was doing
so well no anyway
maybe he'll come back but we're we're
still going to keep an eye
on the five out of fives and we saw
there's still a great tournament ahead
even though we got no laurence at the
top now can't always
get what you want we have these guys on
maximum so let's just have a look at the
scores
and we have angry twin i'm not going to
click on all their names you can have
do that yourself at home matty bar
is um oh i know this guy he's a really
nice guy but i
my memory rubbish strong polish
grandmaster eric hansen
alexandre moscalenko who's i believe the
guy
is he the guy who's written some really
good books on chess no
no maybe maybe i'm not sure might be
he's a good player
pavel penco another strong russian
a lot of russians up there today right
on maxman um
bartel bartel that's right bartel really
really
nice guy strong player um
tinderman i don't know who this is
daniel narutsky okay i'm going back for
uh
me personally i'm gonna support daniel
naradicki
um and you can see there's some famous
names just below and four and a half
ariane terry
is on four and a half champ um don't
know who that is
former prodigy we're just going to go
down see that group
blitzstream doing very well well done
blitzstream and jabarva
jabarva who might be streaming himself
so do go and check out
uh his stream as well occasionally don't
leave me now you know but you can check
out
the stream and the next game started so
i think we're going to look at daniel
naradicki now
because he's one of my tips before the
tournament and
i'm going to blast through the opening
moves very quickly
again i didn't realize the game started
now i can't believe
timmerman has played the orangutan now
there is a rule
any opening that is named after an
animal is bad so just bear that in mind
and daniel naradicki is going for quick
developments
now white has the better pawn structure
because he has more pawns in the center
of the board
but black has very good developments
black now trying to push forwards in the
center
and we can see that daniel has created
some problems by pushing forwards with
this pawn they're moving really quickly
so let me just get up to date with the
current moves
and white very cramped in this position
and we go into an ending and
this ending is where we stand and it
might not be so bad for white but
again the pawn structure is even
evaluate pawn structure
pieces but the
pieces are quite bad for white because
the knight on the rim is dim
night on the edge of the board the
bishop is also very passive
and daniel already has his rooks on
very good squares he now brings in his
knight
to create some problems maybe even
coming into d2
the other idea is just to take the
bishop gain the bishop
pair so bishop here played
trying to pin that knight down and
that looks like a good move maybe white
can try some
rook here but now daniel just supports
his knight
so it's definitely better for daniel in
this position
has daniel ever won has daniel ever won
title tuesday before let's get some
updates come on guys has he ever won it
quite possibly who knows and remember
the live scores
it's 11 rounds if you just come and join
us it's
11 rounds and this is one of the premium
chess events
online it is the title tuesday event it
happens every tuesday you have to be
a title to a title tuesday you have to
be a title player
if you want to play meaning you've got
to be a grand master
feed a master beth harmon or someone
like that
and these are the top 10 players so it's
not open to anyone only open to elite
every tuesday chess.com we're halfway
through
on round six of 11 rounds and it's
blitz chess so it's three minutes per
game
plus one second to move so you get an
extra second
every time you make a move which is kind
of kind of makes it a little bit easier
right
um now daniel going for g5 and you can
see black
gaining space over here with what is a
porn storm
porn storm it's raining pawns hallelujah
at least i didn't say porn that would be
weird when if i said that
um rook c3 now daniel
using his pieces he's threatening to win
the night on a3
so i imagine okay well white's decided
to take that one off
and get his knight to a good square but
there is a phrase about the two bishops
and in this position
the two bishops are looking very strong
look at that poor bishop there that poor
bishop is caged in
is caged in by the pawn on f4 it's
basically trapped
this bishop is just like it's been
entombed it can't get out of its tomb
totally entombed with these guys goodbye
bishop it's just like a piece of wood
it's not doing anything it's been
suffocated
so black i'm expecting will win this one
keep an eye on the clock they're both
under a minute now um
and here well another thing black is
trying to do is get his
rooks to this rank um it was an old book
by nimzovich who was a great player
hundreds of years ago maybe a hundred i
don't know precisely
he wrote a book called my system
which was revolutionary at the time and
that book gave oh i love that move
just trapping the rook in and one of the
things he said was if you can get your
rooks
on your opponent's seventh rank then
that is
going to cause them a lot of grief he
probably didn't say
in those words but you get the idea this
rook is pressurizing but there's a lot
of tactics going on here
white now threatening the rook here but
black ready to take that one
um what um
okay hello to blair as well barbary
mccack
in the chat hope you're doing all right
um
and um you can by the way codders you
can
trust blair barbary mccack he's a good
friend of mine and vice versa
so i would actually bet on narrow daniel
narra dixie to take this one
to take this title tuesday i'm just
putting a little bit of pressure on him
he's doing very well in this game he's
going to win this game
no doubt about it now what's he going to
play here can he even play
some move white is threatening to take
the bishop
but can he allow that to happen and then
bring his
rook into the position here where he's
pressurizing the bishop
on g1 so daniel using a bit of his time
they're both now down to 20 seconds
and instead he just keeps it simple and
he's going to try and pick up that pawn
on a4
just to remind everyone uh bullet chess
is not the time limit here bullet chest
is where you have
one minute each for the whole game it's
basically who's got the quickest wrists
you know
i won't do the quick wrist action and
daniel naradicki
is one of the best bullet players in the
world
so he doesn't mind about the time and
now he has the extra rook
white is suffering if only daniel can
get his rook around to the h file
that could be the end but the other way
to win this is just to pressurize this
square here
so you can try to attack that one the
king a very good piece in the ending
so also this is just completely winning
now for daniel
he's bringing his king up the board
combining it with pressure against this
and it's going to be what we call
zugswang
well okay it wasn't this is going to be
completely winning
bishop goes to c6 i expect no he's going
for mate instead rook h1
next move well done daniel so that puts
him to
six out of six and i'm just gonna see if
any
more of the leaders are playing and it
does look like we might have one more
game
and that was a draw so is that maybe
there's only two players
on maximum points out of about 700 who
started
well done to daniel who won that one
daniel the game we're just looking at
is in second place we have an
international master
in first place which is quite rare to
see because the highest you can get in
chess
is grand master so when they have the i
am next to their name that's only
international master
only it's very hard to get there but
it's not as good as the gm
score so free players it looks like eric
hanson
whoa great to see eric
doing very well if you want to check out
another great stream
uh well a great stream then go and check
out the chess bras
eric hanson streaming on that channel
as well and maybe he's streaming his
games he normally likes a bit of techno
music in the background to to get the
juices going
that's my techno dance or chicken head
as it can also be cool
um now who else is on five and a half
let's just have a quick look at the
score there
so we do have jabarva who
is this maverick chess player who comes
up with crazy ideas in the opening
and he really shows a bit of his
personality there jabarva
kind of reminds me like of ex-world
champion
macau tau and macau tau does remind me
of beth harmon in some way because beth
harmon
was rather excessive of course i'm
talking about the queen's gambit
and um world champion mikhail tao was
very excessive he
had a um a pensions for
uh alcohol and other things but he was
one of the most brilliantly
talented attacking players and there's
some great stories about jabarva
um shall we just stay staying up very
late at night
um and turning up the board the next day
in like the european championships and
then crushing his opponent
in 10 moves or so and so
lots of legendary players but we only
have three players
on six i'm hoping eric is going to play
daniel
naradicki um i don't know who cuban is
so maybe someone can find out
who the cuban is now i'm keeping an eye
on the twitch chat as well so hello to
everyone in the twitch chat
good to see you there
um pip and chuck ginger gm
how do you think you'd do if you were to
play entitled tuesday
i win it easily clearly i just i just
like giving the other players a chance
now and again
you know i can't win it every week can i
you know just go give him a little bit
of a chance
i don't know i i have played in it a lot
you can
check out my youtube channel uh ginger
gm
on youtube and i've got lots of videos
there of me playing
title tuesday and commentating um i've
never won it i'm i'm i
i think the best i've come is maybe top
out of 6 700 players uh i'm too slow i'm
too old and slow now
you know it's a young man's game yeah
i'm 40 years old i might as well put my
slippers on
get my pipe out that sounds wrong and my
hot chocolate and sit on the porch and
just chill
that's where i see myself okay the next
round started so i have missed okay
let's just get an update who is playing
it is
okay daniel naradicki is playing the
other leaders so
i'm gonna get up to date these are two
leaders playing and now daniel's just
played b3 one of the things
i really like about daniel's play is he
plays
every opening and he's now transferred
this opening
as we're going to see into the birds
opening
the birds opening is named after
english player henry bird who was a very
strong
chess player some time ago
and it's like a reverse touch and as we
go on
we can see that we're basically getting
a pretty standard position
in the birds and now
one thing i love doing here is trying to
bring my rook around just to check mate
so does he go for this he does
daniel does try to bring his rook around
but this is a very good break
from black this is black's main break to
liberate the rook
and to liberate the bishop and queen you
can see before
that this pawn was in the way of that
but now after some exchanges
black is going to liberate one of those
and blacks won a pawn
because this pawn on e3 is said to be in
a pin
meaning it can't move because you'd lose
your queen it's pinned down
so daniel brings another piece over it's
not all bad news for daniel
daniel has this brilliant bishop looking
at the black king and a very dangerous
knight around the black king
black swaps off that dangerous bishop
and we're going to get to the current
position very soon but now he's won the
pawn back so he gets rid of the bishop
but he's lost the pawn i'm wondering
here if knight h6 was a possibility
my idea is knight h6 and if you take
here i take on f6
and if you move your king well i'll just
take there anyway i love sacrificing
um but okay he didn't play that daniel
went rook
to f3 instead b5 and now he's got knight
takes g7
put that in your pipe young man and
smoke it
and this has a similar idea this is a
lovely little tactic
we're just trying to get rid of the
defense
the pawn that was defending the knight
on f6
so we're demolishing the king side over
there
and if you take the knight i will take
that one there and it's defended and i
have double
power rooks on an open line are very
good
because they function very nicely on the
open file
so now black counters attack by
threatening checkmate the threat is
queen takes their checkmate
you've always got to watch out for your
opponent's last move
and see what they're doing and now he's
got knight takes e2 what is happening
here
he's trying to keep this knight on pre
knight takes e8
queen takes g3 knight f6 check
king h8 i'm just going to get up to date
with the boss queen h5
threatening checkmate knight to f8
defending checkmate
queen takes peace and now daniel
seems to me to have won a piece at the
end of all that violence
core dear oh and there's a big blunder
at the end there
this is kind of what we call a sniper
queen it's kind of hiding away from
everything
you don't see it cause it's on the other
side of the board and you go
yep i'm coming down for you and then all
of a sudden the queen
whoa jumps to life what happened there
what that that was over very quickly
brilliant play from daniel but i think
i think black must have been doing okay
at some part but
the position really turned when daniel
was allowed to play
knight takes g7 so the big mistake by
black was not looking at white's
dangerous pieces you've got to get into
your opponent's mind
and seeing what his most active pieces
are playing
probably black should play something
like knight g4 here
threatening checkmate immediately
because the way he did play it
with b5 allowed this move and daniel was
winning after that now let's go
to eric hanson's game so eric hanson
can he keep up the 100 score
he's playing champ 2005 who is champ
anyone know by the way did you get a bet
on
i wonder if there was a a little uh i'm
not saying a financial because obviously
that's not
appropriate but blair did you get a bet
on
i'd like to know now in this position
who is the champ
who is who is this guy i'm not going to
click on the name here because it'll
take me away from the scores but someone
could tell me
uh okay that it is renuk
um sadwani okay he he's changed his
profile name right oh it's his other
account so renuk
is a really good player i think he came
second
two weeks ago and did he come third last
week
so he's kind of due for a win and he's
he's really taking
eric hanson to the cleaners here these
bishops look at them he's now won the
rook
there and this one threatens both of
them so the bishop comes to defend it
but
this is this is completely winning for
white of course and eric
is not gonna be on the only person on
maximum is daniel
it's daniel um so
and who did you who did you get a bet on
uh by the way uh blair i'm interested
i'm interested to know who
who's your man we're keeping on the
scores here by the way i'd like to know
what everyone
who everyone thinks is going to win uh
the tournament who i'm interested no
okay so now eric's
getting a little bit back in the game
but he is a whole
rook down and after rook well can you
take that one the only danger that
white's got is his king's a little bit
exposed
so black can now try to come in with the
check
but can we do a checkmate here
okay this is a very safe move get the
queens off the board
and eric can resign here basically
because he's just a whole rook down
king g3 rook h1 probably gonna be
checkmate as well
because the black king is very very
short so
well done to renuk who is he's only is
he only 15 he's only
15 years of age i can't believe
how strong this guy this guy's got an
abundance
of talent 15 15
years old unbelievable and he's now
gone to six and a half we only have one
leader
daniel on um on
seven oh you've got any i am to win okay
that's quite interesting
um that's a bit that's a that's a little
bit uh
that i don't i'm not sure about that
that that bet blair
you guys should always have a little
have a little private private one on the
on the games i think could be quite
funny
my money is on the only leader daniel
naradicki
who does a lot of commentary for
chess.com so you may have seen him
commentate before
so go and check him out daniel
naradikshi has his own twitch channel
so go and look at his twitch channel as
well you can check out my twitch channel
um well ginger gm is basically my name
my twitter account is is ginger
underscore gm so if you want to see what
i'm up to
ginger underscore gm ginger gm youtube
you'll find me if you want to stalk me
you can
you know you wouldn't be the first you
know
um this game is all over the place
what's happening here
white must be doing well okay now this
is a winning
position i guess because of these two
pawns but hang in a minute he's
blundered
oh no it's check blimey
and yeah these two guys are running
right
past pawns they're like running men they
are running
up the board running up the board and
black's only chance is to get through to
the white kings this is a little bit of
an upset
you can see the grades and black is the
favorite here
but he's getting outplayed by white and
he's
trying though to get some kind of draw
has he got a perpetual what i mean by
perpetual
if you repeat the same position
and he has he's managed to draw
unbelievable
they managed he managed to draw that one
if you repeat the same position
three times in a game of chess it can be
a draw you can claim a draw
um okay so that's a very good save
um by is it savion
uh savannah savannah that's how you say
it savannah young
russian grand master um okay
now there be another break after the
next round after round eight just to
update you
on the scores um was that a draw in the
end it was a draw okay
just to update you um on the scores at
the moment well you can see the list
here it's seven rounds
of 11 have been played we're getting to
the crescendo
of the tournament there's only four
rounds
left and daniel naradicki
the popular streamer is on maximum these
guys
biting at his heels oh we have the
exotic
princess i'm not going to talk too much
about that handle
um i've talked about it a lot it's
probably one of the worst handles you
can have but
there we go he's one of the strongest
players we can get away of it
eric hanson dropped a point but he's
still up there with a shout
on six out of seven i think the winning
score could easily be
10 out of 11 it could easily be 10 out
of 11.
so um that is that's worth bearing in
mind
and so these people is is hikaru
still in the mix i don't think he is
but we do have the likes of mvl
who is in the lead in the challenger to
the world championships over the board
in real life
and he's got a good chance of even
facing magnus carson for the world
championships
uh aneesh giri is up there i don't think
he's streaming today he's been
blundering a lot and the
next round is off so i'm gonna now look
at jabbar's game
it's always interesting to see this
maverick player
how he's getting on if i can find his
game while
i mean the daniel naradicki game is a
big game as well let's stick with this
one
because this is maybe a key game to
decide
the whole tournament we have daniel
naradicki and we go for the opening
moves he goes b
free again and he's playing this
incredibly talented
with 15 years
now the way the reasons oh
why is that okay sorry about that for
some reason you had echo there i think i
pressed the wrong button or something
happened that was weird okay
no echo anymore it's always good to have
a little bit of echo
don't you want to hear me twice hear me
three times i could put you on
put myself on three times if you want
the idea of white's opening here is to
prove that this bishop can be a very
good piece
but by doing that white gives away a
space advantage
and black gets a very big center
and having a space advantage is very
useful
in chess and by that i mean black's
pawns are further advanced
into white's territory white is a little
bit more cramped white hasn't advanced
any pawns
past this rank on the other hand black
is sort of controlling
uh all of this rank here now let me just
update has it really been frozen or is
that
an error on my end let me just see if uh
i'm going to refresh the page quickly um
which probably is not going to help is
it let's see if we can do that again
yeah i thought that okay we're going to
go back we'll just update the moves
there it did freeze a little bit
but on the other hand white has this
brilliant bishop so it's
it's kind of a thing between those two
things and now both sides developing
quite quickly and after castles
queen h4 black starts the first attack
and black's threat is to just crush on
h2 here um bishop b5 check
means that black can't castle and of
course you want to get your king safe
when you're playing
but the king can now not castle because
it's probably gonna have to move
um and this is a very interesting
position i i
i don't know who i prefer probably
prefer white
but when black does move the king it
kind of i don't know if renuk has some
uh problems with his connection is that
possibility
hope it's not my connection because he's
moving very
slowly at the moment okay he has moved
and i think you have to and now
i'm wondering about ge5 does black play
this move because this pawn
is the one pawn blocking that bishop so
you want to get rid of that pawn and g5
is one way to challenge the pawn on f4
if that pawn on f4 can be removed you
have checkmate coming up on h2
uh i expect a4 will be played here oh no
he's got in here and he's threatening to
take the e4 pawn i kind of like white's
position
because this pawn is very weak black's
king has
not castled and that means the rook is
trapped
on h8 that rook on h8
cannot get in the game is trapped there
and this pawn here may just be lost um
oh no he didn't do that what did he do
okay so queen e7 can we just go queen e2
queen c2 oh g4 wow
and now take this pawn daniel naradicki
doing very well i think if he wins this
game as white
he's got a very very big chance to win
the whole whole thing he'll be on eight
out of eight and he is a pawn up now
black's only
chance is to try to get at the white
king i feel
because the white king you could say
that the pawns in front of it are the
bodyguards
and here the bodyguards have gone a
little bit further away
i don't think that's a major problem
because
white is protecting himself very well
there
black gets a threat he threatens that
pawn so white
defends the threat white must be better
but actually
now h5 very clever move
black trying to use the rook if he can
open up the rook towards h2
it would be well let's just say pretty
juicy
and he's now put in this little move in
the middle where if you take that one
it's checkmate
anything is possible now any result is
possible
i think black has won a pawn back time
situation
they're both getting to less than a
minute and at least i think for daniel
he's managed to swap queens off
you have to say ramak came up with a
brilliant attack there from nowhere
i think it's now time to have a look at
the pawn structure and the pieces
i still like white's position because
this night having a knight in the middle
of the board
is really good it seems to dominate the
bishop
this bishop is stuck on a very bad
square you can't get rid of this knight
you could you have no pawns with black
to attack that night that night
will sit there forever just sit there
and be like
i'm just gonna sit here i'm just gonna
enjoy myself in the middle of the board
you can't get rid of it and now daniel
try
this is getting worse and worse for
black this pawn here really weak
really weak porn and i think white's
king is quite safe the rook
does a great job of defending it but the
main issue is just this pawn can white
take it straight away
i probably wouldn't because my night is
so good
you can take your time it's best
not to pick the grapes in early season
wait until they get a bit of maturity in
them and then you'll have a much
nicer crop of wine when you pick them
don't get the immature grapes get the
exotic
nice older grapes but he has eventually
taken that pawn and i'm not sure he
should have done that because black's
got his rook down to be free
um and is runak in a bit of time trouble
the answer is yes i don't know what's
happening here
what are we gonna predict i mean it's
it's a draw
ah boom
i'd be a good chess spectator wouldn't i
i'll be sitting there draw
boo i wish you could do that at chess
tournaments you know live chess
tournaments i mean it might
put off so many other players but any
time a draw
is agreed you can go boom get out of
here
you know like they do and execute
execute them
we don't want to draw we don't want to
draw um
i think i think i should have a button
ready where we have that and i can make
some
make some sort of nice sounds going on
okay but
i mean at the end of the day that's not
a bad result and we have for daniel
because he keeps his lead but someone
has joined him
it's the exotic princess strutting his
stuff
at the top there which is going to lead
i mean jabalva and one more player
alexander
catshow oh hang on a minute so blair's
bet is
in blair had a cheeky bet
that cacho was an im was going to win
the tournament you're back in it blair
you're back in it so we've got three
players
at the moment on seven and a half and i
mean these two players i'm sure have won
it before has daniel naruto
won title tuesday before i'm still going
for daniel naradichi but i really
am a great fan of jabarva i don't know
the guy the international master in
first
um and it's tightening up the field
there's three games left i'm gonna take
a another break now there is a break
after round eight
i'm gonna stop myself up on a bit of tea
so cheers you can get a little bit of
tea in if you want to
a little bit of green tea i feel keep
the energy up
and um i'll be back very shortly so i'll
be back in a couple of minutes
don't go anywhere um we've got loads
more
exciting action to come and go and get
yourself cup of tea and we're going to
get ready for the
end of this fascinating tournament three
rounds
to go who is going to win this week's
title tuesday
can daniel narodicy keep his lead
over the other players see you soon back
in a sec
[Music]
it's looking really ominous especially
given that he's down on time this is the
magnus carlson squeeze
um wow hicaro's playing in front of
hundreds of people
imagine being in his shoes right now i
mean
up by four games no i can resign yeah
carl knows that it started with 16
players
and uh it all came down to one man
magnus carlson
[Music]
and this is a pretty great matchup i
know people love hikaru nakamura
hikaru is the favorite for a reason he's
the beast an
absolute monster it has been hecaro's
speech his championship this 2018 in car
nakamura the overall 1c takes it home
in the species championship
obviously this is a rematch of last
year's scc final what a finish by the
way i mean that's been the story of the
match the kara nakamura has just kind of
out swindled out tricked and out
calculated wesley in the critical moment
dude that's a nice move wesley's shaking
his head
ikaro wins the pawn he's going to draw
this game i can't believe it which that
happened
unbelievable nakamura holding that
position he had no business throwing
that game
[Music]
well we're back again for the last
segment of uh this
title tuesday event i'm actually just
looking
uh this is really funny you're gonna
find us very amusing
i've been looking just at the chat in
chess.com
uh not on the twitch chat but actually
under the game and daniel naradicki
is chatting uh on on the thing
and uh apparently i don't know if we're
going to get confirmation on this but
daniel naradicki is apparently
on an airplane and he's playing
on his phone on an airplane is that is
that
is that actually is that is that true
how can you get good internet connection
on your phone uh on the airplane i i i
don't understand that i don't understand
that at all
so i'm just looking at the chat and he
says give me some slack i'm on an
airplane
i don't know maybe it's a maybe it's a
euphemism or something i don't know
interesting so um he's he's doing pretty
well for someone who's playing on his
phone
on an airplane um and
um yeah interesting stuff and we also
got some information
that daniel uh won the first
ever title tuesday event so
uh he certainly won this event before um
i you know that was a while back
obviously when was the first title
tuesday event i don't know when was it
when was the first title tuesday event
anyone know that
um it keeps one one thing i don't know
one thing why twitch does this it keeps
doing the echo
it keeps doing the echo is that right uh
okay but that should be all right now a
little little technical issues probably
me clicking around too much
so anyway um the next game's gonna start
very soon
we've got three games left let's just
have a look
at the list of leaders very
very exciting um
finisher that could happen we've got
these three alexander cacho
of russia i don't know who this guy is i
don't know is he another
russian prodigy quite possibly
and then we have daniel narrative we
talked a lot about exotic princess
leon beast is mvl from
france very very strong player
champ is i'm really impressed by this
kid's play he's
15 years old i mean what was i doing
when i was 15
i was being very naughty and not playing
much chess that's for sure
um but yeah what a what a potential
champ he is he's got a good name there
um and angry twin is another
international master up there on
seven this group on seven points could
also
um win i think the winning score this
week
i reckon it will be 10 out of 11
but i might be i might be wrong of
course so that means
these guys have to get
two and a half out of three to win i
reckon it either be 10
or it will be nine and a half that's my
guess
vivit another strong player and let's
just scroll down a little bit
we've got penguin penguin is
well he beat hikaru last week one of the
fastest
players one of the fastest draws
in the west he's amazing amazing bullet
player
i saw penguin once play i think it was
blindfold 15 second
bullet so what that means is he had
15 seconds not for one move
but for the whole game he had to play
the whole game
in 15 seconds and he was blindfolded
so he couldn't see what he was doing so
he could only see the
i mean it just it's just the
discombobulator love
that word i was like for a bit of
discombobulation
in the nation oh yeah hello to fiona in
the chat as well
i hope you're doing well fiona go and
check out fiona's
twitch channel which is fian shetter
it's it's legendary it's a legendary
channel
um could see so many of you in the chat
today
anisha's kind of up there but i don't
think he's gonna win it
on six and a half i think seven points
is really the group
hikaru is little he's biting on the
heels there
he's on six and a half he's doing a
little nibble he's nibbling away
he's saying i'm gonna win my next free i
might still get in the money honey
am i still getting the money we will see
so the games
have started and we're gonna have a look
now
at all this is a big game mvl
versus jabarva these are two
brilliant players now mvl
with the white pieces really must
win this one to have a chance because
he's half a point behind
but he has the advantage of the white
pieces the white pieces is kind of like
having the serve in tennis you know you
get to smack your opening
in your opponent's face take that take
take the spanish
have a bit of english opening okay
and we have quite a solid approach from
jabarva here
shabbath is known for his kind of
obscure
and unique openings but here he's given
mvl a lot of respect that mvo is simply
developing
maybe the bishop will come here or here
the early stages of the game control the
center
get your pieces out and get your king
castled
now the pawn structure i would always
say that white is a bit better here
because white has an extra pawn in the
center of the board now that might not
might not look like much but having an
extra
central pawn is quite a big thing it's
quite a big thing
it can help you later on and a normal
approach here which
grand master keith arcol uses a lot is
what's called the minority attack
and that is this is a more positional
game than some of the other ones we've
seen and when it's positional it means
that both sides pieces
are not really as active you can see
that the bishops
not really doing much they're just
waiting so more often than to do
with how you use your pawns and the
minority attack is when you attack
your opponent's majority of pawns with
your minority so these two pawns
can aim to attack these pawns here oh
look at that a bit of green
a bit green eh a bit of green
and um we might see that coming up later
on on the other hand
um jabarva has decided to to
just pressurize d4 another approach i
might consider here is using the h-port
to try and why i love pushing harry the
h-born
to try and to um
attack the king there um
so um this okay but you can see he's
going for the minority appoint
his report is that film the minority
report
he's doing a little minority attack and
i think
he's gonna maybe play on both wings now
oh no he's come in the center
interesting decision so he's opening up
the center of the board
and i think that's because his bishop
was trapped
and by clearing up all the pawns in the
center
the bishop here might come to life so
he's trying to get this sniper
better range give it a better range
um and now the position is continuing
with maybe pawn takes here
and something like rook d2 but the
danger of playing like this
for um okay he's grabbed the pawn
but now black's gonna grab the central
pawn to me it looks very even
this looks like a very even game i don't
think
mvl should have played that move that's
a little bit rushed
sometimes when you're controlling the
position it's much better just to wait
and try to build it up little by little
you can always
press the turbo charge button
and if you're controlling the position
but pressing it too soon
can lead to lots of simplifications and
the more pieces that get swapped off
when it's equal material the more likely
to a draw it's going to become and
this should be a draw but it doesn't
mean it will be a draw
mvl now thinking how he can try and
cause some problems
he's got to be a little bit careful of
his back rank
um so he's played g3 so that his king
has another escape square
on g2 but this could be a mistake look
at the bar
the bar has massively changed queen a1
queen a1 this seems really strange he's
gone here instead oh queen e4
check trying to fork the king and the
rook
so if you take on b7 queen e4 and this
is what's called a fork
attacking two pieces at once so after
queen e5
now mvl has to come back and defend
and black certainly has a better
position now for a start black can just
win a pawn
on a5 could jabarva win
this game and that would be very good we
have penguin
just looking at the scores keep an eye
on the scores below
there's only two rounds left after this
one penguin is shot up
and this position now very tricky for
mvl
black is a porn up so he blundered with
this g3 move
g3 was too slow uh can chabada win this
one he's trying to get his king a little
bit safer
and if i was black here i'd be trying to
maybe create a past pawn so mvl would
stop that one by controlling that
instead chabad has got another way he's
trying to play this he's trying to
exchange queens off and go into a rook
ending
one thing i know about mvl is that his
rook endings
are brilliant mvl is such a good
defender
when you're one of the best players in
the world
you have to know defend and he's gone
for this one very interesting decision
and if pawn takes pawn black will beat
two pawns up
but then white can get his rook behind
the pawns
and when you're okay he's done this way
he's going sideways i thought he could
have come
um oh no that didn't happen sorry
getting excited there
okay he has he's got his rook behind the
passport
this is end game technique and grand
masters
generally always know where their pieces
should go in the ending
and this is why chabath has moved his
rook back getting your rook behind the
passport is key
and he's not in a rush to take this one
black's winning plan is to come over
with the king
and then support the pawn coming forward
so you've got to use the king and the
pawn to come forwards like this
um very good winning chances on the
other hand
mvl needs to try and create some chances
over there over there he needs to bring
his
king in and try to win one of these
pawns at some point
white's going to have to give his rook
up for the pawn because otherwise you
can't stop it
these guys literally just come forward
like space invaders
with sound effects that took a lot of
effort but i don't know how he's going
to do this
okay well he can go king b2 b3 i think
it's winning for black it must be
because there's no way that white can
win a pawn over here
okay he's gone for it but this pawn rook
b7 is winning
rook b7 is the winning move at some
point surely
get your rook behind the pass pawn that
would be winning if he plays that is
winning he's done it
rook behind the past pawn jabarva is
gonna win
brilliant result from jaba he's leading
and now this pawn is unstoppable i don't
think there's
any way you can even give your rook up
for the pawn
and of course the black king now gonna
take everything
only chance here is to play rookie one
this is the only chance
but this must be winning now because you
can get your rook
your rook up you get your rook behind
the one pawn oh this is brilliant
and now we come up and come here still
very close
but this is the winning way and there we
go
it's checkmate next move very nice
finish as well
and that does there's two players in the
lead and it's two of my favorite players
daniel naradinsky one again well done to
daniel apparently
playing um maybe playing on an airplane
and we have jabarva jabhava generally
streaming as well so you can check out
his stream
it's always good to spread the stream
love i feel
vidit is up there this group on eight
out of nine
very good chances but there's no real
ims up there
the only i am is in sixth place he's
gonna need to get a couple of wins on
the board there
uh penguin good to see him i don't know
who two pack is
he's come back from that he's come back
from the dead two-pack
what's my favorite two-pack song i'm
trying to think now
what's my favorite i can't remember any
two-pack songs shame on me
and vidit so it's really exciting isn't
it
really exciting i'm just to see if
there's any more games we can leave it
on
uh while we have a look favorite two
pack songs
calefanya okay you're not going to get
me singing now that would be
really embarrassing yeah would no no no
no no no
no no no i was tempted i need i need
i i'm on the tea today i certainly need
wine or something before you get me
singing
i mean i don't know i don't know if
chess.com be very happy
if i drunk a load of wine and then
commentated it would be very amusing
but i'd probably lose my job so um
you'd definitely get some singing out of
me what'd you guys reckon do you want
windups no no no no we're not going
there
i'm sticking to the tea i'm sticking to
the tea
being very well behaved um so
at the top let's just have a look um the
penultimate round
is getting very close to starting
we're in round 9 of 11
and there's only two more games to go
the time limit
three minutes plus one second to move
and you don't get knocked out is your
accumulated score
quite important and i haven't actually
got that
very well shown i'm gonna just let me
just do
one oh round ten started let's not worry
about that we're going
straight this is the game this is the
game
whoever wins this game will probably win
the whole competition and i have to say
it's a bit tough for jabbar who gets a
second
black in a row jabarva is black again
whoever wins this game will win the
whole competition
are they going to agree a quick draw and
try to win the next one
jabarva's going for the black lion come
on black lion him
and someone's done a very good course on
this
and i really do like this system for
black it's very solid
but again most ground masters prefer
white's position
because white has the space vantage
meaning he has two pawns in the center
of the board
and black only has one but daniel now
taking that pawn off
so we get a symmetrical pawn structure
meaning that there's no advantage in the
pawn so it's all coming down to pieces
if the pawn structure is reasonably
symmetrical equal
then there's not going to be many
weaknesses there it's who's got the
better pieces and it looks to me
that white has the better pieces this
bishop attacking f7
this bishop could be very useful for
attacking that square but it's not a big
thing
black's pieces on the other hand this
bishop a little bit blocked
so a little bit but if i if i was white
here i'd bring my knight to f5 now
get the knight in get the knight nearer
the king this knight's not doing much
will he play it will he play knight h4
will he play i like i'd love to see him
play knight h4 here
is he going to play it is he going to
play if you're wondering where i'm
streaming from
it is sea world is it sea world there is
actually a place
oh he's gone the other way okay he's
gone the other way he's trying to bring
his knight out this way
the one problem that black has here is
this bishop
so this is the issue there's a place
actually off the south coast of england
or the east coast of england
called seaworld which is basically this
place which has claimed itself as its
own country but it's actually like a
fort
from the war i don't know why i'm
talking about this just in case you want
to
know about sea land sea land that's the
one sea land
and um yeah it's got a really
interesting history they basically
claimed this fort um as their own
territory
really weird but why am i talking about
c why why how did i get onto sea land
anyway back to the position it looks now
that white is really going for it
whatever the result of this game
you've got to say to daniel who could
have taken maybe an easier approach and
gone for a draw
you've got to say to daniel i like your
style because he's
throwing all the pieces at black's king
and i like the way
he's at least trying to win rather than
taking a draw
he's going for it and he's now
maneuvering another piece
over to attack the black king funnily
enough though
the computer really likes black's
position
but jabbar decides to go into a little
bit defensive
bringing the bishop back to defend these
squares
daniel brings another piece into the
attack even though the computer likes
black i have to say
i would take white here because i love
attacking
and saying that jabarba's starting
counter play in the middle of the board
he has
the open file daniel going forwards
remember
whoever wins whoever wins
this game is probably gonna win title
tuesday the prizes are
four prizes it's a thousand dollars for
first prize
not too shabby you might be able to get
a little piece of sea land with that
potentially um and
the knight comes in so what is okay well
this could be a sacrifice because
now black is thinking black could play
knight takes d3
pawn takes bishop takes b3 winning a
pawn
but now it's white's turns have some fun
and white has one
two three four pieces attacking and
white could play something like
knight takes h6 and if you take that one
back i come in here
showing the dangers of the position
so back to the game bishop takes f5 i
think black had to get rid
of that dangerous knight and jabarva now
aiming to swap the queens off the board
this is very clever play from black
white's queen is very dangerous as we
saw in that last position
so he's trying to get rid of the queens
and now he's centralized his queen
i have to admit now it's looking good
for jabbar he's picked
up a pawn the exotic princess
is showing her charms knight takes e4 i
think daniel was in serious trouble here
his attack just didn't work
black has defended brilliantly here very
nice defense from black
bishop to e3 where's the queen gonna go
it'll probably
no it can't go there because then the
knights on pre
can it go to okay he has to keep an eye
on the knight
this is the only thing because that you
can easily work out
if a knight is okay or a piece is okay
and defended if you calculate how many
pieces defending that night
this knight here and the queen here so
i've got two pieces defending
how many pieces are attacking that
knight the bishop here and the queen
so there's two pieces attacking in order
to win a piece you have to have more
attacking
than your opponent has defending so
um that didn't happen knight g4 daniel
was playing very risky
jabarvas won the rook but daniel was
going all out for the attack
all out for the attack knight takes f6
can white check mate with these three
pieces somehow
i don't think so you can see just how
strong this bishop is this bishop
defends
the king side this is why black did that
very clever move and moving the bishop
back here
um does white have any chances it's
looking
really bad for daniel but keep an eye on
the clock funny things can happen
when both sides get short time which
they are here
bishop c4 aiming to attack the pawn on
f7 and i think it's still looking good
for black but
it's looking actually looking a little
bit more dangerous because there's a big
threat if
white can take on h6 the black king
becomes very exposed
so he's found a way to defend but now
he's won a pawn so this is actually a
little bit unclear
a little bit unclear now bishop g5
bishop g5
can you play bishop g5 this could be
very good bishop g5
rook takes f7 no could he have done this
move let's have a look bishop g5
and if rook takes f7 bishop takes the d8
but instead daniel has played bishop f4
but look at the time
queen d7 bishop g6 this is a critical
moment in this week's titled
tuesday competition the black king is
now looking really exposed daniel is
coming up with some great
attacking pieces and moves oh i don't
know maybe daniel is going to do it
he's going to do it i to be honest i
think in this one
it's the typical case that chibava was
doing well
but when you're playing blitz chess it's
more important
maybe not to be doing well but to have
the initiative and now white is
completely winning he might
okay bishop takes f5 look at this rook
daniel was winning queen g6 is a big
threat he's going to be going crazy
jabarva is going to be going crazy this
is checkmate bishop takes f6
is coming or queen h7 checkmate in one
move
is check mate what a turnaround well
done to daniel
unlucky to jabalva oh
what an end to the match that was that
was a
brilliant end and you have to say
ja baba's chances have now been lost
uh it's afraid afraid afraid it's gone
that bad way
and daniel naradicki turned up the heat
there at the end let's just have a look
how it happened
around here jabarva has won a pawn but
you know what daniel says and this is a
brilliant thing to do we can all learn
from this
when something goes wrong in your
position and it's gone wrong for white
here
because the black knight has won a pawn
there is something that's saying okay
i'm just going to go all in
i'm going to take many more risks now
that the position has gone wrong and by
that
you can just go oh you know to hell with
it have my rook
have my rook i don't care and instead
i'm just going to go straight for your
king this is like the kamikaze approach
obviously the famous japanese pilots
when they were losing the war they're
like okay well look i'm just going to go
for it i'm going to give my life up to
cause as much damage as i can
and you can see this kind of happening
now with
the king and the problem is black is
doing well but the king is
more it's more in a precarious
situation compared to white's king which
is very well defended here
so and that was the the telling thing
and as the game goes on
you can see that white's bishop starts
to create
real havoc here creeping in to the
position
now if you want to avoid the ads you can
obviously subscribe to the channel
do remember if you do subscribe there's
so much stuff on chess.com that you can
that's going on and it's a good way to
support uh presenters like me and the
people who make these shows possible so
you know it's an easy way just to just
to get good
free content um okay so
we're going on um i think is it penguin
you should be concentrating on your
games
you know you're in second place penguin
you're playing for first
so penguin is in the chat and twitch
which is quite amazing and look
he is now on nine points and he's
playing against daniel naradity
this is gonna be one major game if
penguin wins
he's gonna win the whole thing oh yeah
oh yeah
oh yeah i'm ready i'm ready
i'm ready oh yeah i hope he's not
listening to the commentary while he's
playing
to be honest that would be a terrible
idea if he was listening to me
suggesting moves on his own game
he wouldn't be at the top of this chart
he would be
i think more down the bottom so yeah but
it's very interesting to see the scores
who else is up there hikaru
has made a little comeback he's in fifth
place
so hikaru's on a bit of a roll of wins
as well
um and we just saw jabbar lose that one
so it's the last round
let's go and we're this is the game
for the whole championships is all on
this
one penguin needs to win
if penguin wins you've got the scores
below me
if penguin wins with white he gets 10
points and he wins the whole thing the
winning score is going to be 10 points
at least what's going to happen here
guys
is white going to win this is what it's
all come down to it's
all come down to this last
last game white needs to win to take a
thousand dollars
but more importantly the champion of
internet chess
the title tuesday we have a kings indian
defense i'm
i have to say i'm so impressed just by
um in general daniel naradicki's
approach i know he had that draw
but his approach he's taking lots of
risks
and playing the king's gambit which is a
really risky opening
when you maybe only need a draw to win
it is like right
come on i don't mind let's remember if
daniel does draw looking at the scores
he gets the 10 points and no one can
catch him
so black needs to draw or win and this
is this is really exciting
um now penguin playing queen d2 i don't
know if he's going to go completely
crazy and start pushing his h-pawn
is he going to go h4 h5 no he's playing
it much more sensibly he's just going to
castle
black i don't really like black's
position because these pawns seem a
little bit weak
and you've got to look out for where
there's open lines and there's an open
line here
and penguin has an idea of just
attacking that pawn
later on on the other hand daniel's got
to play aggressively and he's done that
and maybe he's going to try to bring the
bishop out here and we can see that
penguin is
attacking that's called a backwards pawn
it's a pawn
that's on an open line where your
opponent can tack it so that's a porn
weakness so
white has the better position but
anything again
can happen here i don't like daniel's
opening choice when you need to
draw you should probably go for a more
solid opening it's very risky playing
this
crazy king's indian when you only need a
draw
queen e7 played well is still in the
balance
at the moment anything can happen um
who do we think is going to win i'm
interested to see um
queen e7 and can white now play d5 this
is what he's thinking of
with the idea of attacking that one you
can play d5 let's have a look
so you could go d5 placing that knight
under some pressure you can't take this
one because now bishop takes b6 wins a
piece but black can go
c5 here i don't know if penguin wants to
do this
he hasn't he's gone bishop f2
the idea of this one is to vacate that
square
for one of his worst pieces and his
worst piece here
is the knight on d1 the knight on d1
can now move to that square this is
typical grand master maneuvering
you look at your worst pieces this
knight which is clearly
a problem piece it gets in the way of
the rooks and you think
okay where do i want to put that knight
and you try to think of a better square
so i think this is his idea i mean
another move he could have played was
knight to b2
and then bring the knight somewhere like
c4
the problem daniel has he hasn't got
much activity here what can actually
black do
you want to have pawn breaks in your
position and black
doesn't have pawn breaks here if he goes
a4
queen takes b4 just wins a pawn
in the position uh and oh no
oh no his connection now let's remember
daniel is on an airplane oh no he's
going through turbulence
daniel is playing this he might be the
first ever person
to win title tuesday in
30 000 feet in the air or however high
an airplane goes but his connection's
gone
his connection's gone no his
connection's gone
look you can see the red thing his
get out turbulence the plane the plane
get your connection back plane
oh he's probably shaking there now get
the connection back this is oh no
this could be a horrible way this could
be a horrible way to the title tuesday's
done
don't come on come on aeroplane come on
aeroplane
i can see him now connection connect to
wi-fi
aeroplanes wi-fi is terrible connect to
he should have got a first-class seat
because then the connection would have
been better
it's going to cost him dearly here can
it connect you know
get on he's doing it 20 seconds can he
get the connect button
15 seconds connect connect
connect luggage is falling on his head
someone's drink goes straight in his
face and he's still oh no
he's connected he's connected boom no
he's connected with six seconds left oh
my words
oh oh but he's blundered a piece he
panicked and he's blundered a piece ah
poor i have to say poor old daniel that
was so harsh
he connected with four seconds left but
he made a move
he's wiping the drink off his face he's
he's you know he's got a suitcase on his
head
and he's plays a move and it's a blunder
oh no
and unfortunately oh no what happened
there the move he played was a blunder
oh no
and of course he lost that one oh that
is
quite a sad end but at least now
he can ask the stewardess can i have a
napkin please
i've got to get the drink off my face
and i'll have a large whiskey please
i'm also suing you for your internet
connection
that cost me 750 you're going to see my
lawyer
next week does he actually does he
actually have
does he actually have a case to sue them
does he i don't know can he sue them
maybe he can sue them maybe he can sue
the aeroplane for this
for the internet come on i want to see
that in the news
anyway all out of all i have to say i
have to say congratulations to penguin
and to be honest
penguin did absolutely nothing wrong and
if we go back to the position
here where all the drama happened
penguin's a bit better in this position
he's got more pawns in the center
he's got the open c file and
there's no reason he should give daniel
a draw it's not his fault that daniel's
on an airplane
you know imagine how strong daniel would
be if he's actually at a computer
and not on an airplane i've never you
know that would be the first time
anyone's ever won title tuesday from in
in the air but it hasn't happened and
daniel has now
dropped down congratulations to penguin
is it the first time that penguin has
ever won
is it the first time that um everyone
daniel
so unfortunate there we heard that
you're on an airplane
you did so well your connection went
just at the wrong moment
oh we were cheering for you a bit there
but of course
daniel sue the aeroplane sued the
airplane we now have daniel in the chat
which is great
um i would sue the airplane for their
dodgy connection
oh i'm sorry that's such a bad such a
sorry finish but
i have to say congratulations to penguin
it might be the first time penguins
ever won title tuesday he's a very very
talented player
and there's still a couple of games
going on there's four places that pay
out
and we actually only have an nm which is
lower than an international master lower
than a feed a master
and it's i think it's short for
normalized
master nominal master as that's what it
is nominal master
nm what could it be short for
knobby master no beast i i don't know
i'm going to be rude here if i keep
going
so oh hikaru hikaru's popped up to third
place okay i'm going to see if there's
any more games going on
hikaru hikaru somehow recovered
to third place he's in third place now
and that's a really good
recover from hikaru who had some bad
games earlier on the top four places
seem to to give prizes and we're just
going to look if there's any more games
going on the games are slowly
ending now and we're going to have a
look at who's
won the prizes daniel naradichi it was
bad
turbulence did you get a drink in your
face
daniel did you get a suitcase on your
head
this is what we want to know i can just
imagine you on your phone literally
jumping all over
trying to play the last round i can
picture it now just trying to
try trying to use your finger to get the
connection button
while you're while you're all over okay
you did get a bit of water
thrown all over you oh no daniel well
look
i have to say you did amazingly well for
coming second
considering you had turbulence over the
rocky mountains
on a plane i mean i don't know if
anyone's done that before so
um congratulations on on that good
result
that's really funny actually okay let's
have a look at the scores there's only a
couple more games going on
uh penguin congratulations
go and check out penguin's twitch
channel uh hikaru
has now overtaken daniel on tie break
oh another blow to daniel
another blow ah no his last five minutes
has been horrible
hikaru takes the silver medal but well
done to ikaru daniel
in third place and some other scores
here
i think anyone who finishes i mean it's
such a hard tournament
anyone in the top 20 is done very well
well i mean that's only because i dream
of coming in the top 20.
and we'll have a look down vidit 9 out
of 11 good score
jabarva 9 out of 11 and niche there's
some big names there
eric hanson was up there as well
so there we go oh that was intense
that was intense guys well i hope you
enjoyed that um
for uh you know as much as you
as much as possible it was extremely
exciting this week
and a bit dominated by american players
so well done to
us of a who got really for i mean
penguin's got his flag up as oh well
well done to north korea
that is just naughty isn't it north
korea come top
uh i think penguins actually from
america
so it's an american one two three
congratulations to to the guys at the
top
really well done we got the winner in
the chat so congratulations
to penguin well done penguin i don't i
don't know but they don't have
they don't have covid in north korea do
they apparently so maybe it's the safest
place on the world to be
because there's no covid in north korea
i'm probably going to get assassinated
by them now now okay i'll stop there
i'll stop there
don't get myself in trouble i have to
keep reminding myself
these things don't get myself in trouble
don't do it simon be careful now
um um yeah so
we can check out all these guys at the
top all the free people they all have
their twitch channels
go and check them out go and subscribe
and follow them penguin hikaru daniel
if you want to look at my stuff it's
ginger gm twitch
dot tv slash ginger gm and you can check
out my youtube channel as well
which is just ginger g if you just
search ginger gm
you'll you'll you'll find me somewhere
um
so what a brilliant event okay well i'm
gonna now show you a bit of a hype video
and then we're gonna wrap up the show
have a great night everyone
enjoy yourselves a great day depending
where you are it's been a load of fun
thank you very much
and stay tuned just to see the hype and
get some information on some
great things coming up
[Music]
it's looking really ominous especially
given that he's down on time this is the
magnus carlson squeeze
um wow hicaro's playing in front of
hundreds of people
imagine being in his shoes right now i
mean
up by four games well i can resign yeah
carl knows it it started with 16 players
and it all came down to one man magnus
carlson
and this is a pretty great matchup i
know people love hikaru nakamura
hikaru is the favorite for a reason he's
the beast
an absolute monster it has been hecaro's
speech his championship this 2018 and
car nakamura the overall 1c takes it
home in the species championship
[Music]
obviously this is a rematch of last
year's scc final what a finish by the
way i mean that's been the story of the
match the car nakamura has just kind of
out swindled out tricked and out
calculated wesley in the critical moment
up dude that's a nice move wesley's
shaking his head
ikaro wins upon he's going to draw this
game i can't believe it which
happened unbelievable carl nakamura
holding that position he had no business
drawing that game
[Music]
you